I already know this because I was told
but that Japanese it's it isn't just
regular Japanese no it's not it's
traditional Japanese which is so
incredibly difficult to learn
imagine regular Japanese is quite a yeah
yeah I mean I didn't realize that I was
I was being taught traditional Japanese
until actors that came into to shoot
Shogun world who spoke modern Japanese
were like oh my god how are you doing
this because even for them it was quite
tricky but yeah it was amazing
come and can you speak it a bit now I
can yeah I can actually
I don't think of what I'd like you to
say ketsumatsu Hashim Ashoka there were
cattle now Sami Enoshima oka
did you just ask me on a date okay
[Laughter]
in traditional Japanese you could just
say yes which is height no what did you
really say I said let's lay down our
swords and have a dignified conversation
which is more traditional we kind of say
that backstage didn't wait you just know
gee can you speak any job because you
were just in Japan I think came from
Japan couple of days ago really they're
doing publicity for I love dogs the way
this happened oh that's funny everybody
was so nice and wonderful they're very
sweet and beautiful they had at the
premiere we had a premiere and
and Wes Anderson was there a couple of
sumo wrestlers came to add color and
original something or other and we tie
took a funny picture with him yeah
[Music]